hey um i have a solution to your problem
and it may not have worked the first
time but um here's an alternate way of
doing it um when you have
safari open
and you go to your downloads window like
where before and open the containing
folder
you will have the mac os 10 cursors this
is where you double click on it you know
extract all files
and first you have to
extract all files and browse to a place
that you know
so i saved it to
my username program documents and then
ls10 cursors so i'm going to do is exit
out here
and first of all i'm going to find where
i extracted it to so i extracted to
computer
um
here no i extracted it to
sorry
you go to my username and my documents
i can find these things
and program documents so here's the
actual folder i'm going to minimize this
and what i'm going to do is go into my
computer
go into your local disk
double click on windows and find cursors
double click on this cursors files
folder
and then you're going to go
to where you saved this
right click
and cut
and then come into here and right click
and paste
the macbook 10 cursors folder uh you
don't have to extract every single one
and put it in individually like this
just put the folder in here if i were to
double click on the folder all those
files will be there
um and that is another way to get them
to show up in the control panel mouse
menu so if i open control panel now
and i go down to mouse
or go to control panel home
then go to mouse
and go to pointers
the os 10 cursor should be there for you
so i hope that helps you um and else
those questions
um
go ahead and subscribe and go ahead and
um post a video response or comment or
something like he did and you'll get
your answer so i hope that helps you
thanks for watching peace